we're very close I people keep asking
keep telling like what's your plan have
you read books I have no plan and I've
read zero books so that's the type of
Mom I will be I'm not like a prepper I'm
just not that way it's gonna be great I
trust the process
um Tom has Googled enough for the both
of us he's like Mr Google so he could
probably deliver this baby at this point
but I'm just like I'm like this I'm just
like it's gonna be great but that's how
I've gone through life yeah I love that
you you both bring something different
to the table so you know there's
excitement on both ends what are the
qualities that you're hoping to instill
in this little baby girl my girlfriend I
was on the phone with someone the other
day and she said because I've had a
question about something she has a
newborn as well and
um I said I just I don't know what I'm
gonna do and she goes your baby's gonna
tell you what to do and I was like I
loved that I was like that I know I tell
people what to do and if this child is
anything like me
she's gonna be like this is what I want
and I just need to listen yes you're the
queen and you've got a queen in training
exactly so I'm gonna listen to her you
have been working for over 30 years you
haven't taken many breaks and I'm just
curious if that is something that you
see in your future maybe taking a step
back as far as shooting I will
definitely take the next few months off
um probably not much more than that
though really you're just eager to get
back into it and wear all the hats she's
gonna come to work with me I've got help
I've got you know she will be in tow no
matter what and you know Tom and I both
love what we do and we we've really made
a commitment to each working at
different times and so he'll be working
over the next few months I'll obviously
have a big break and then when there's
something that whether it's flight
attendant I don't know what it will be
that I'll go back to he'll take a break
and we'll kind of trade off so that's
really that is our goal and we're hoping
I think that's going to work for us but
um again who knows where this was the
first for both of us
with baby girl Pelfrey due this spring
Haley is glowing and excited but she
admits one year ago and just before
meeting Tom she struggled with
depression therapy helped her through I
learned a lot about myself and you know
made good decisions made bad decisions
obviously went to therapy still in a lot
of therapy changed my life and I
remember being so depressed couldn't get
out of the funk and I thought oh my God
I knew my therapist kept saying you have
to walk through the fire and once I got
to the other side crazy enough I I met
Tom and so I and it happened you know
right when I thought it couldn't get
worse and I tell my friends you have to
walk through it and what's on the other
side is is really beautiful heading on a
family trip Kaylee creatively hides her
baby bump in her most recent project a
Super Bowl commercial for Priceline my
work here is done when you think about
your commercial airing during the Super
Bowl knowing that a hundred plus million
viewers around the world are watching
you simultaneously is that even a little
surreal I think so I think that anybody
that's in a suit that has a commercial
or any sort of AD running during the
Super Bowl is such a cool thing it's
such a big deal I've become a massive
football fan over the past I would say
couple years and so I don't know this
one just means even more
um because I'm so excited for this game
so I will definitely be in front of the
TV we're having friends over and if the
commercial comes up that will be um that
would feel very cool I must say what
brought you into the world of football
kind of like later in life what made you
get into it honestly I have to be honest
Tom is so obsessed with football and his
team is the Giants and so when I met him
it was kind of like here are my loves
you my career in football and so I had
to kind of learn and I loved football
before that but not on this level I hope
that doing the Super Bowl commercial got
you brownie points at home you know what
I don't think he knows that this is
gonna air during this Super Bowl so I
might just leave this as a surprise
right he's in the middle of like eating
his slider his hot dog and yes baby
you're on TV yes I love it and as if she
wasn't busy enough Kaylee is shooting a
new dark comedy based on a true story
for peacock due out this summer
producers rewrote the script to include
her pregnancy the best part about it for
me is that I get you to be pregnant eat
whatever I want
yeah wear like the most comfortable
clothes everyone treats me like a queen
I have like 17 different chairs on set
it's just been if you're working up into
your end of your third trimester which I
am this was the way to do it it's been
um obviously the first time in my life
I've ever done this so they've really
taken care of me and amazingly enough I
actually think it's a great part of the
show but what I love you know this
character has been written in such a way
that we didn't change a lot because she
was pregnant and I mean that in the way
of she's still wearing crop top she goes
to the pool she's there's like there's a
lot of like sex and there's all this
crazy stuff we didn't change anything
because she's pregnant we felt like you
know what like she's still the same
person and nothing should change you
know because you're pregnant we're
really excited about this peacock
project but does that mean that it's the
end of the road for the flight attendant
does anything ever mean the end I mean
no we we can't you know you never say
never I've definitely learned that the
hard way it does not mean that for
flight attendant we're still talking to
our kind of group of producers and
writers and trying to see if we can come
up with something super special for a
possible season three it's definitely
not decided yet it'd be amazing to do a
third season if we could if we have the
right kind of um path on how to get
there I'm just not quite sure yet but
never say never
[Music]
foreign